im baden-württembergischen neulußheim
werden am bahnhof nach vielen jahren der
planung neue aufzüge montiert
barrierefreiheit mehr komfort so der
plan bisher blinken sie aber nur munter
vor sich hin funktionieren tun sie nicht
und das obwohl er schon seit sage und
schreibe drei jahren gebaut wird
ich bin auch oft mit dem fahrrad
unterwegs das heißt ich muss das fahrrad
würde ich die ganzen stufen hoch tragen
es ist eine zumutung also menschen mit
behinderungen ältere dame mit rollator
oder jemand der im rollstuhl sitzt wie
soll das funktionieren
ich finde es ein unding normalerweise
müsste sich kostenlos fahren weil die
strache jeden tag mein fahrrad 50 stufen
hoch und 50 stufen runter
gerade die bahn so großes unternehmen
rückzug sowas fertiggestellter können
ruckzuck geht hier gar nichts schon seit
oktober 2017 wird gebaut und gewerkelt
satte 2 millionen euro kostet der umbau
den steuerzahler der bund der kreis und
die gemeinde bezahlen das ganze die
deutsche bahn baut und die kommt nicht
zu potte im örtlichen rathaus verliert
man langsam die geduld drei jahre
brauchen um zwei fahrstühle zu bauen bzw
drei jahre plus xs ist nicht abzusehen
wann es fertig wird dann ist da kein
verständnis mehr da ja und selbst wer
als bürokraten können dies dann doch
nicht mehr nachvollziehen
auch schwer nachzuvollziehen im juni
also nach ganzen drei jahren hat die
bahn kürzlich bemerkt dass noch
zusätzlicher strom nötig ist jetzt liegt
zwar eine neue elektroleitungen in
richtung fahrstühle rauf und runter
fährt hier aber trotzdem mix und so
stehen die reisenden vor verschlossenen
aufzug türen und müssen fahrräder gepäck
und kinderwagen weiter rauf und runter
schleppen wir fragen bei der bahn nach
warum es so ewig dauert zwei simple
aufzüge zum laufen zu bringen
schriftlich heißt es auch wenn ein
aufzug von außen betrachtet bereits
fertiggestellt wirkt und der eindruck
entsteht die aufzugsanlage wären nun
innerhalb kurzer zeit betriebsbereit ist
in der regel noch
vieles zu tun aha das hört sich nicht so
an als sei hier in nächster zeit mit
einem geregelten fahrstuhl betrieb zu
rechnen
ich denke bis die dann mal in betrieb
sind sind die wahrscheinlich schon
wenn es dumm läuft veraltet und es ist
doch finde ich eine ziemliche schande
dass es nicht fertig wird und so bleibt
den reisenden in neulußheim nichts
anderes übrig als sich weiterhin die
steilen 52 stufen hoch zu schleppen und
ordentlich zu schnaufen